into any situation I have a look at  myself and I say listen if it gets Peak  I'm walking the best thing to do I'm so  grounded like that but that's yeah I'm  around I'm around the church remember  all the time there's no there's nothing  you can't you need to look at it like  this here before I met you  you were before I met you just an  attractive woman and then we got  together and the feelings grew and all  this kind of stuff but I don't need you  in my life I didn't need you before so I  can still live without it gee I mean so  um yeah I'd love to have that have that  talk with yourself though because  otherwise you get lost in the sauce and  it's crazy and you might do something  stupid and then you might be in jail or  something like that and she's moving on  anyway it's done for real you might you  might be in jail yeah